this is not a dog you heard me right
blue from Blue's Clues is not a dog sure
she looks like a dog and she barks like
a dog but she is not a dog get this blue
is in fact an advanced member of an
alien species looking to learn from
humans in an eventual bid to take over
planet Earth an alien species that is
getting closer to achieving that goal
season by season and here's the craziest
part this is barely a theory as you're
about to see practically all of this is
explicitly spelled out in the show's
Canon so sit down in your thinking chair
and think think
about your impending servitude to an
army of canine themed overlords
that's alien for sit and obey
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that's really found its Niche
talking about the dark Lore of
programming starring puppies it is a
very specific content category but we
are dialed into it for those of you who
have no idea what's going on today we're
talking about Blues Clues the iconic
Nickelodeon kids show that ran for 10
years between 1996 and 2006 before
getting revived in 2019. every episode
was an interactive audience Adventure as
the animated dog blew in her human
companion roamed around their storybook
house in order to find three clues that
would help him solve the episode's big
mystery honestly when you look at it
this thing was like the training ground
for theorists of the future Blues Clues
walked so film Theory could run along
the way they'd sing songs read the mail
and do stuff like this we need our handy
dandy
notebook right
you know the good sort of formulaic that
any kids show really thrives off of the
show was hosted by Steve for Four
Seasons Who then went off to college and
passed the Baton over to his younger
brother Joe now in its current iteration
Blues Clues and you it's hosted by their
cousin Josh all wearing primary colors
all equally oblivious to the obvious
answers that are lying right in front of
their faces does she need to put the
bubbles between the towel and the soap
and and make a bubble sandwich sure
Steve sure your dog blue wants to eat a
bubble sandwich try it see how much dog
vomit you're cleaning up out of that
carpet anyway Blues Clues is probably in
my opinion one of the best kids programs
of all time if you've never seen it who
taught you how to feel I guess I just
wanted to say that after all these years
I never forgot you
ever and I'm super glad we're still
friends me too Steve I didn't forget you
either who was cutting onions in here
anyway now that my family's exhausted
the entire Canon of Paw Patrol and is
currently waiting patiently for the new
movie to release later this year we've
moved on to revisiting some classic
Blues Clues in order to fill the void in
our Friday Night movie nights and let me
tell you as I've gone back to this show
as an adult I'm picking up on a lot of
small strange details here and there
things that seriously make me use my
mind and take a step at a time and I
gotta tell you it's time to do the thing
that I want to do which is expose Blue's
Clues for the alien conspiracy that it
is you see the colorful storybook World
a Blues Clues holds a secret in its
later seasons and spin-off movies a
secret that re-contextualizes the
entirety of the show for decades we've
been led to believe that blue is a puppy
nope she is anything but she is an
emissary from the Stars scouting out us
earthlings and our Reckoning is coming
friends so skadoo on over because it's
[Music]
child
oh a clue a clue oh what did you say you
have the flu sorry to hear that I've
been sick too lately you can probably
hear my voice it's been a really nasty
winter so far no a clue oh you see a
clue thanks slippery the first clue is
the Subscribe button let's put that in
our handy dandy nope
wait comp tablet right so we draw one
long line at the top a long line at the
bottom connect the two with some rounded
lines at the ends and then we write the
word subscribed in the middle wait does
yours not look like that you better fix
that otherwise mailbox is gonna cry and
you don't want to make mailbox cry do
you let's begin in a simple Place shall
we Blues age the sheer fact that blue is
still alive in the new reboot series
automatically throws her dogness into
question considering that she should a
hundred percent be dead at this point
you see in the world of the show there
is clearly a passage of time that's
established for the most obvious example
of this in season four Steve goes off to
college there done time is not a frozen
entity inside this universe season 5
episode 29 tells us the story of how
Steve first met blue at the time she was
a young puppy and Steve looked to be
about eight years old which tells us
that they were together for at least 10
years before Joe entered the picture now
in season 2 episode 9 Blue's Birthday
Blues cake has eight candles in it and
we're not talking dog ears either I
think we've all heard the general rule
of thumb that one year for a dog equals
about seven years of human life so if
your dog is two real years old its dog
age would be about like 14 right well it
turns out the math isn't exactly that
simple dogs mature more quickly than we
do early on in their life size and breed
also play a factor with smaller dogs
tending to live longer than larger ones
so knowing that what would Blues age
expectancy be well based on her large
floppy ears she's likely one of the
breeds from the hound family we also
know that blue talks a lot in yowling
barks and high-pitched wines
this also fits with the Hound group as
dogs bred for hunting have a very
similar distinctive sound and tend to be
more talkative than other dogs because
they had to communicate with their
humans while on the chase but the thing
that actually clinches it is her weight
we know based on Blue's visit to the vet
in season 5 episode 30 that she weighs
in at 20 pounds which would put her as
one of the smaller Hounds in other words
blue most closely resembles a beagle
giving her a rough life expectancy of 15
years at absolute best the record for
the oldest dog in history is 22 years
and I doubt that they were as sprightly
as our puppy blue here so if blue was
ate at the top of season 2 and now 23
years later we have this new reboot
there is no way that she would still be
qualifying for puppy status let alone
living status if she were actually a dog
what's that maybe time froze between the
season breaks I mean you would think
that but no time continued to March
forward for all of the characters case
in point Mr salt and Mrs pepper in the
season one finale of Blue's Clues the
big mystery solve is that these two
seasonings are having themselves a baby
named paprika it is really cute it's by
the fourth season paprika has become a
toddler two years have passed in two
seasons in season four the family has
themselves another child cinnamon by the
series rap cinnamon is still a baby that
can barely talk but hold on in this new
reboot series Blues Clues in you
everyone is older paprika is a teenager
with a smartphone and cinnamon is
probably around 10 wearing a cool
sideways ball cap the full 21-year gap
between the original series finale and
the reboot hasn't passed but it has been
at least a decade for the characters
inside of this world meaning that blue
is likely 21 years old or older that is
not a dog who is able to dance party and
freeze on a single toe and the lies and
the deceit about Blue's age don't stop
there if you jump to the reboot and
watch season 1 episode 11 happy birthday
blue count the candles on the cake not
only has she not aged apparently she's
aged backwards her cake only has five
candles three less than what she had
when it was her birthday with Steve the
evidence here just doesn't add up and
before you think that maybe this is a
new replacement dog it's not it is
confirmed to be the same Blue from the
old series by both Steve and Joe Steve
Joe I don't know what blue wants with
her snack let's talk to her hey blue
talk to me
we talked it over and there's really
only one thing to do please so if it's
the same dog 20 plus years later how can
blue still be alive and kicking the only
reasonable explanation is that blue
isn't a dog at all but to prove that we
gotta find ourselves some more clues a
clue a clue tattoo tattoo yeah I got one
on the small in my back it's a cute
little butterfly why do you ask no Matt
a clue oh a clue and it's on Blue's paw
print isn't that meta so why would
Blue's paw print be a clue well it's
because her Anatomy isn't like a dog for
starters she's able to pick up books
with an opposable thumb you don't have
to be a vet or have a masters in animal
scientist know that dogs do not have
thumbs and yet on many occasions
throughout the show and the promotional
artwork we see blue holding things
rowing rafts holding a Piping Bag or a
guitar all with a big old prominent
thumb a thumb that is somehow able to
retract back into her hand sorry let me
rephrase this Blues hold paw is able to
morph and change salute normally has
herself three obvious toes as she hops
around the house this is consistent to
our design across all iterations of the
show and yet when she goes up to smash a
paw print on the screen for a clue or
during the intro sequence she grows a
fourth toe and also again there's that
humanoid monkey thumb that's hidden
somewhere in there too this is not
normal dog Anatomy why has this not
raised anyone's alarms before and the
non-dog behavior doesn't stop there
either in season 6 episode 8 soccer
practice blue and the Gang play a game
of soccer after they're done they all
sit down to share some chocolate ice
cream yep you heard that one right
chocolate ice cream I think most people
know that giving a dog chocolate is
basically like giving them poison but
ice cream is just as bad for the dog it
can lead to bloating and vomiting but
here at the end of the episode both blue
and her friend magenta are eating
chocolate ice cream clearly there are
two imposters Among Us and right now
blue and magenta be looking mad sus
whatever she's doing she is clearly not
a dog how then can I prove that she's
from another planet well just by
watching the show in season 6 episode 1
the legend of the blue puppy Joe and the
Gang are watching a blue moon all of a
sudden Moonah the moon fairy appears I
came here all the way from the Blue Moon
tell blue about her Legend as the story
goes on the night of the very first Blue
Moon a whole litter of puppies just
appeared out of nowhere but one was
different from all the others she was
blue her color wasn't the only thing
different about this puppy this puppy
like to read and listen to music that is
not a dog that is an alien trying to
look like a dog and failing miserably
it's also at this point that I should
probably mention Blue's other origin
story in season 5's holiday episode we
find out that blue again is No normal
dog instead she appeared out of a
storybook just because Steve wished her
into Reality Steve did not have his
present yet but he knew exactly what he
wanted
I hope I get a puppy Steve gets this
mysterious book in the mail from an
unmarked package about a blue dog who
doesn't do normal dog things but the
other puppies ate their food from a bowl
on the floor
blue sat at the table in a with a fork
and a spoon we're told that blue wants a
friend who can teach her all the songs
and stories and games the book then ends
with the most abrupt fourth wall break
imaginable and then looked up she had an
idea could her friend be you that night
blue jumps out of the book using the
magical power of skidooing and the rest
is history now it would seem like the
blue moon and book stories would
contradict but they don't in fact they
just repeat each other they're just the
same story being told differently blue
is a creature that came into being
because of the Blue Moon and was
immediately different from normal dogs
that much is very clear and it would
seem that one power that the moon
puppies possess is the power to skadoo
hopping into fictional worlds like books
and paintings this is a skill that seems
specific to Moon puppies like blue who
are then able to pass along those
abilities to their caretakers who get
exposed to her notice how shocked
everyone is the first time that she
skidoos into a world but eventually
they're all doing it whoa did you see
that blue just went right into the
picture of that farm that's so cool I
think blue wants us to follow her
whoa she's in the picture with all the
shapes yeah blue just skedude we can't
do
this is my first skidoo you ready
anyway blue wound up inside of a book
waiting for the right human caretaker
who would then be able to teach her
human ways but skidooing isn't her only
magic power returning back to the Moon
fairies and the legend of the blue puppy
episode we see that blue has an even
greater ability she was the smartest
puppy in all the land
and the legend says that there is
something else that made the blue puppy
special spoiler alert is not what you
expect she was born with a little golden
key but she didn't know why she had it
or what the key might unlock yep a
mysterious key late season Blues Clues
gets to some weird places man the tldw
of all this is that blue is finally old
enough to unlock her secret ability the
key which has been hidden inside her
alien dog stuffed animal the whole time
hint hint opens Blues magical playroom
blue transforms into a giant puppet and
she can talk the greatest thing about
your playroom is that here you can talk
to your friends but I can talk to you
wow that is your greatest gift no no no
thank you I'll just go back to the
Barking please what's also interesting
is that time moves differently inside a
blues room we can actually see from the
clock in the background that each Toy
Box segment here doesn't run as the same
time outside of the toy box the whole
thing functions a lot like the
hyperbolic Time Chamber from Dragon Ball
Z where Decades of training can get done
inside the room room in mere minutes of
real time so is this a similar sort of
facility is Blue's Room a place for blue
to hone our powers of human speech seems
like the next clear Evolution for blue
species so if blue were to harness her
true alien powers within Blue's Room
what would the fully evolved form of
blue species look like ladies and
gentlemen allow me to introduce you to
rainbow puppy the newest addition to the
roster added as a part of the reboot
rather than just being one color rainbow
puppy is as you might have guessed a
rainbow RGB gamer for life more
importantly though she can speak fluent
English and walks on two feet rather
than four like blue and magenta not only
does this make rainbow puppy less
dog-like she's clearly a more powerful
version of Blue in season 3 episode 11
of the reboot rainbow puppies Skidoo
Adventure we see that she can Skidoo way
more than blue ever could in most
episodes blue only manages to Skidoo
like once maybe twice but in this
episode rainbow puppies skedoos into
chalk world the post office the farm the
ocean the theater rainbow world and
finally Skidoo world seven times in
single episode she is clearly far
stronger than Bluer magenta ever were
and on top of that she doesn't have an
owner blue and magenta both have owners
but I'm guessing rainbow puppy doesn't
because of her abilities she doesn't
need a caretaker like the others because
she's a fully evolved version of
whatever alien species these creatures
are meant to be will the same happened
to Blue will she soon have enough power
of her own that she no longer requires
an owner absolutely you can actually see
the start of it once blue unlocks her
room Joe her caretaker at the time is
completely sidelined he doesn't know
where Blues disappeared off to heck he
doesn't even learn about blue's room
until we tell him there you are blue
so did you find it did you find your
greatest gift so
what is it
oh
that is so cool he's clearly left on the
outs well you two are lucky to have each
other you and blue blue and you
great friends with Steve it was always
about his relationship with blue but
once blue unlocks her final ability Joe
serves no purpose he's not needed
anymore it's all about you the viewer
the one who's allowed inside of Blue's
Room in fact Lou is so not interested in
Joe anymore that she doesn't even play
Blues Clues with him Joe has to be the
one to create the game himself I hope
you liked finding Joe's clues because I
sure liked leaving him maybe we'll play
again sometime soon we would not Joe is
an afterthought the humans have served
their purpose we even catch glimpses of
blue standing on two feet in the
recently released movie she's starting
to evolve into a higher powered being
she's starting to approach the levels of
rainbow puppy in this new Blues Clues
movie we see Blue's powers to an extreme
degree she is able to do a whole boss
through a billboard to get to New York
City and while they're in New York
everyday items like a mailbox mustard
and salt and pepper shakers come to life
as blue walks past blue has the ability
to create living beings so we've
established that blue is clearly not a
dog from Earth but what's the goal here
well after sitting down in my thinking
chair to think think
I realize Blue's true purpose she's
trained enough to become the next
rainbow dog and so what's rainbow dog's
deal domination and rainbow puppies
could do Adventure we see Skidoo world
for the first time ever the world that
Josh and blue travel between when they
Skidoo in this world I noticed a few
interesting things one it's rainbow
colored showing rainbows control over
this meta space but secondly we see lots
of pictures throughout Skidoo World
these aren't random photos either they
all represent different Skidoo locations
throughout the series The Planet picture
represents season 2 episode 4 what
experiment does blue want to try were
they Skidoo into space a jungle is
season 2 episode 4 of the reboot Blues
big baking show where they Skidoo into a
jungle and the gingerbread house is from
season two episode 6 of the reboot lose
night before Christmas with a Skidoo to
the North Pole these aren't just random
places this world holds all the places
that Josh and blue have been traveling
to and it holds the magic that makes
everything come alive this isn't just a
portal it's a hub world when any of the
puppies could do the power to go there
again is stored here in this skadoo
world they're capturing different
locations across the world allowing them
to have simultaneous control over
everything blue and rainbow puppy may
seem friendly but believe me when I say
anyone that claims to be a dog but can
walk eat chocolate and have opposable
thumbs is someone that cannot be trusted
get as far away as you can from Blue and
her friends because she could be
skidoing to a place near you and never
ever go into blue's room alone they're
all just using you instead you should
probably just say so long there's no
time for one more song If you manage to
do that my friends I gotta thank you for
doing your part you guys sure are smart
but hey that's just a theory a film
Theory and if you want to watch the dark
secrets of Dora the Explorer or check
out the video on the left spoiler alert
that game's programming gets real weird
or if you want to check out why you
shouldn't trust Ryder from PAW Patrol
that video is on the right now if you'll
excuse me still looking for that third
clue anyone anyone see this clue